o pessoal seja bem vindo a mais um vídeo
e hoje vou ensinar como fazer um estojo
utilizando papel esponja é um papel com
uma aparência mais ou menos normal de
elementos mais grosso e vai responde é
compacto e você encontrou está vendo nas
categorias se vocês vão encontrar em é
porque vocês não estão uma portaria saiu
de uma tesoura com a gente em casa
o papel higiênico também toda a gente
está em casa coloque quinta e usar
porque isso é mais rápido mas se vocês
não quiserem podem usar outra qualquer
só que vão ficar será mais tempo aqui
eis o material está mais pra frente
porque o tamanho opcionais vocês não
tiverem não tem problema nenhum quanto
em fazer os dois na mesma então bora é a
primeira coisa que vocês têm que fazer
executar dois círculos com o diâmetro do
roubo papel higiênico para segurar as
coisas no sítio certo e utilizei uma
mola mas ela acabou destruindo um pouco
esponja então o que eu recomendo é que
você segura em com os dedos do modo que
as pontas conhecida nesta partida muito
importante que vocês ponham cola na
parte da esponja que entrou dentro do
tubo do papel higiênico e não na partida
ficou para fora
por que vocês fizeram para fora vai
lutar depois que não vai ficar muito
bonito cai então com muito cuidado façam
como vocês estão vendo vídeo para o
custo igual do lado e do outro é muito
importante que vocês ponham a mesma
quantidade de esponja dentro do tubo
papel higiênico e os mais ou menos uns
entre maio do lado e 15 de maio do outro
lado
caso vocês querem fazer o mesmo foi que
vocês viram na parte inicial do vídeo
corta em dois cêntimos por dois
centímetros de cada lado o estojo e foi
um povo indicou ledo que do lado usando
cola mas quiserem por um faichecleres é
só vocês quiserem direto e não tira
parte dos quadrados ou então podem
também usar a imagem verde por políticos
você escola dois irmãos um de cada lado
e vai fechar na mesma
para deixar os dois mais resistente usei
um pouco do fio e como orgulho fui
correndo desta maneira vôo é bastante
simples e banho rápido e vai aumentar
bastante a existência do vosso 2
mas vocês colocarem bastante cola
naquela partida opõe às bolinhas é não
fazer isso mas eu acho que fica tem a
questão do design fica mais bonito desta
maneira
executar uma faixa com mais ou menos de
três centímetros de largura e depois tem
que desenhar desta maneira uma parte
grande pois uma parte mais estreita
depois uma parte grande outra vez isso
foi vai encaixar nesta parte que os
todos em aragón hora de ter um mecanismo
bastante simples do faixa mas funciona
muito bem nos preocupa em por vós sois
não vai abrir
para finalizar o projeto seria adicionar
um pouco de frio nesta partida e acabei
decolar e se fica no mesmo estilo com o
resto do estojo e esse é um projeto que
ficou bastante bonita eu acho e bastante
econômico e que em inglaterra um estojo
mais ou menos com esta aparência fica
entre 4 e 5 libras o que é bastante
dinheiro ia conseguir fazer isto por
menos de 50 centímetros
esse pessoal só ganhamos o fim muito
obrigado investido até a próxima